ありがとうございます
はい  えっとですね 先ほどのお母さんに毒を飲ませた少女ですけども
普通では考えられないようなこと
そういう大事件なんですけどね
それに対してまあ褒め称える人がいるとか
弁護する人がいると 片やそれを少女に対して怒りを表す人もいるだろうと
仏教徒としては あの 許すということもあるかなと思ったんですけどね
例えばそういう悲惨な場面では
カルマという  あのね 許すとか許すまいかと関係なく
罪は罪なんですよ あんたは仏教徒として許したんだからと言って
その女やったことには何のこともないでしょうね
で ただ それによってこちら勝手に怒ったりしたっても何のこともないし
しかし まあしょうがないやと思ったら
それとんでもないことになる
自分にもその罪が伝わってくるんだからね
まあ子供だからそんなことっていうのは
あまり善悪判断できんだからあり得るとかね
そういう気持ちになると
自分もその罪に染めてしまいます
だから仏教とは許すか許さないかという話じゃないんですよね
しかし それっていかに悪いかとかね
そういうことっていうのはね
それはよくものすごい大きな問題であると
それについて語らないということはすごい罪なんです
なぜならば 人々にそれ指導がないんだからね
仏教徒だからで黙っているぞとかね
それ自体不自然な行為なんですよ
自分のこととして考えるっていうようなことってよろしいですか？ 何を
少女がしたことを  私もあの女が可哀想やと思いますけど
私はどれほど可哀想と思うんだかというと
人間じゃないと思ってるんですね
生命として人間の形で生まれても
可哀想に これに動物のレベルよりも以下の精神でしょう
もうしょうがないと これすごい批判で聞こえるけど
それすごい心配して言ってるんです
気持ちとしては もしかすると
もうどこにでももう育てることはできな--できないぐらいの精神状態ではないかなと
で これ間違いはもう科学者がやったんじゃないんですかね
学校でもどこでも全国に科学と変なくだらんことばっかり言ったりすると
この研究したい気持ちになるんです
私も小学生でいろんなカラクリ研究やっていたんだから
まあ学校で教えるものいろいろあって面白くてたまらないんですよ
帰ってきたらその方向で物事を考えちゃうんですね
いろいろ実験してみたりするんですよ
時々失敗したって すごく怒られたりして
一回もう何か電気がショートしちゃ--させちゃって
私はもううっかりしたらもうもうもう燃えてしまう
建物燃えるということもあったんですよ
で まあ見事にそこで電気損耗してヒューズが焼かれちゃったんだから
無事問題なかったんで
さっさとバレる前に全部まあ処理しておいたんですけどね
どうも何か教えてくれるとやってみたくなるんです
でもまあこちらもう仏教文化だからね
生命に対してはもうそれは絶対もうやらなかったんですけどね
でも いろんな動物のことでも教えてくると
やっぱり動物を捕まっちゃうんですよ
捕まえて調べるんです
いじめてはしませんだけどね
例えばカエルの指は動けるように何か何か付いてるんだぞと
ちょこっと見たら見えますけど
それに足りません ちゃんとカエル取って指のるほどと
だからまあ そういうところで問題があったんじゃないんですかね
猛毒は猛毒で だから化学
化学とか ちょこちょこちょこちょこっと微妙なところだけを教えてもらったことはありますけど
例えば触らせないんですね
いろんなものは これはこういうもので触るなよと
あんたらと 最初からもうすごいもう脅し
その私たちの先生たちはね
例えばハイドロクロリックアシッド
ナイトリックアシッド
サンフィルアシッドとかあるでしょ？いろんな酸の類とかね
で 机の前にサーッと並んでますよ
研究室に行ったら座って授業を聞いたりして
サーッと並んでます ちゃんとサルフリリックアシッド
ナイトリックアシッド
あれ 何て言いますか いろいろまあ英語の単語しか知らんだけどね
で 例えばシルバーナイトレードってやつがありますね
あの 銀AuのTreeなんですけどね
ああいう信号なんて言いますか
で これって猛毒やと何のことなく言うんです
銀が入ってますけど それでまあ簡単に分解するんだよということを教えたい場合は
もう先生だけちょこっと持って何かにちょこっと入れてみるとすぐ黒くなっちゃうんですね
なるほど しかし猛毒やと
こういうもの触るなよ
これってのはものすごい危険であると
で見せとんですよ いかに危険かと
ちょっと触れただけでもものはもう溶けてしまうとかね
だから事件はなかったし
自分では触ろうという気持ちはまるっきりないし
まあいろいろ強烈な酸
いろんなアセチレンやらいろんなものは店でも普通のいろんなことに売ってはいるしね
でもその知識でも守るっていう
もうそれはもう我々子供の管轄じゃないと
知ってるんですよ 知っていたんですね
ずっと一回だけ事件です
私の場合は もう家ではいろいろやっちゃったんですけど
もう実験室で何か実験して何かこぼれちゃって
で あまり気にしなかったかな
それで話に夢中になって
こう話してると一滴がこっちに付いちゃった
そこをちょこっとまあ焼けてしまったんですけど
それそう大事なことではなく
ちょっと皮膚がやられただけでね
それ以上事件はないんです
ガス買う時でも まあもうやらせてくれない
もう完全管理 で かなり脅しがあって
怯えてやって 結局は何言われるかわからないし
まあこういうものは手で触るもんじゃないとか
もう勝手にとかね 例えば測るはかりやりますね
あのなんてかあります
それでもう0.5グラムと0.1グラムとかって
もうもうこんなの手で手で触っちゃうと
これで変わりますよと
すごい脅しかけちゃうと
もう怖くて こちら測りたいんだけど
まあ先生がはいと言って入れてあげたりはする
じゃあ自分で計算しなさいと
だからそういう風に このもうどこかで自分の命ぐらい守るってことも教えてないとね
だからこれでこれでこれはどこでこうなるんだぞとか言うと
じゃあやってみようかなという
それでもいいんです これを動物実験して
それから人間人体実験もするんだからね
だから何のために科学やって
それ一言葉ない世界でしょ
だから元々大体そんな言わなくたっても
子供っていうのは一応人間だから
そんな悪いことしませんだけどね
だからなんでこの子をと思っちゃうと
やっぱりまあこの世に生まれるべきではなかったかもしれませんしね
紛れ込んだ可能性もあるし
[背景音楽]それで結局はもう生きる権利を失ってしまったし
一番残酷っていうのは
この母親を人権実態人権体にしたことっていうのはね
一番もう子供を信頼するね
もうもうもう食べたら吐きたくなるぐらいまずいものを料理作ったっていうのは
子供はやった子供やったことだからね
ああ良かったという親でしょうね
親っていうのはね これはまずいとかね
食べられません 言わないんですよ
子供なんか作っちゃうと
子供に本当に大丈夫か
食べられるかないかと
先に自分で食べて試すものでしょう
親っていうのは そういう人を人権実体実験に使っていうのは
便利に見つかったもんですね
そういうことだから やっぱりこの悪いことは悪いものであると教えてあげること自体がカルナでしょう
そこをくだらんことで
まあそんな被害者を非難してはいかんとかね
それとこれ話は違いますよ
彼女を非難して もうもう処刑にしなさいと言って暴動を起こしたっても
それで問題解決しないでしょうに
それは悪行為であって
でもどれくらい子供たちの場合は犯罪
次から次と起こるでしょうし
誰も真剣にその問題を見ていないんですね
だからまた次にまたケースがあって
また次のケースも出てきた
それからその情報をしっかりとは言わないし
ただワイドショーを作っちゃえばいいんだからね
だからまあ道徳的に まあ善は善で
悪は悪であるということはまあ教えなくちゃいけない
それはケースでケースで言わなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様もそういうことをしたんですよ
何か悪いことが起きたら
そのケースを見事にとって
それをむちゃくちゃ非難してやるもんじゃないやと
こんなものはと言って
それから禁止っていうことにするんですよ
法律も道徳も やっぱり設定する場合はケースとして必要なんです
日本の社会ではいかに変なもう異常現象があるにも関わらず
そういうケースとして扱わなくて
もう偉そうな知識ぶっちゃって
もう被害者を応援して
それで終わっちゃう 加害者応援して終わっちゃうんです
今されている報道によりますと
少女はあんまり反省の色が見えないというか
多分おそらく子供を動揺させないために怒ったりしてないんだと思うんですけどね
周りの人たちは  怒る必要ないんでしょうね
私に任せちゃえば十五分で全部言わせてもらいます
あと別の事件なんですけども
やっぱりあの 留置されている人に第三者がですね
手紙を出して その人がその手紙を読んで
そのだんだん心が変わっていくというようなことがあったというふうに聞いたことがあるんですけどね
それでも一旦罪を犯した人は
それからは心変わるかもしれませんだけど
それにより社会は犯罪を起こさないようになるかどうかっていう
また別でしょ 一人が子供
子供殺された親 父親がね
テレビであったんですけどね
ずっと活動して で 講演に行ったんですね
その何とか少年院と何とかところで少年院に行って
そのもう被害者の立場からね
子供殺されて自分がどんな気持ちでいたかとかね
どれぐらいそこは苦しかったかと
堂々と喋る そうすると加害者たちが
やっぱり自分たちがカッとなって
何もちょいちょいな子やったんですけど
加害者という側もあるんだよとよく分かったんだと
自分たちには想像できない悲しみをね
そういう人々に与えているんだと
それでその人は講演終わって土下座して
この加害者たちの前でいきなり
これからはもうそういう人に悲しみを与えないでくれと
お願いしますと もしそういう気持ちになったら自分で死ねと
人を殺すんじゃなくて
それでそのグループはすごいショック受けちゃってね
まあそれでしっかりするかどうかはわからないんですけどね
うーん だからそれが学校でも言ってほしいんですよ
犯罪を起こしていない子供たちに
社会のために行動するというのはそういうことなんです
難しいんですよ もうもうもう宗教全然捨ててる世界だからね
だからすごく難しいと思いますけどね
まあキリスト教文化も表に出してね
道徳成り立ちませんしね
表に出しても仏教に至っても宗派ばっかりで
誰に頼んだらいいかわからないしね
だから難しいとは思いますけどね
それでももうなんとか頑張らないと
社会っていうのはね こんなこと起きちゃうと不幸もいいところでしょうに
たとえ加害者となんとかいったって
それも一人の子供でしょうに
かわいそうというか かわいそうなんですよ
もう元気で大人になって寿命を全うして生活をね
死ねるのに ちょっとしたことで全て失ってしまうというね
子供を大事にするならば
子供のことを心配するならば
やっぱりそういうところはもう酒を持って酔うか脅すか
もう何でもいいんですよ
もう一つですか あの元の偈でですね
ヘラーヤンタマラチャンダニーというところがあるんですけども
タマラチャンダニーは文法的にはどういうふうに考えたらいい
文法的というのは  例えばこれは女性名詞として考えた方がいいのか
男性名詞として考えてもいいのか
これ中性でしょう  中性ですか
うん  タマラとチャンダーのコンパウンドで
うん  それがニーになってるということは
女性名詞の語尾に近いという感じがするんですけども
でも中性名詞でもニー入るでしょ
中性名詞にもあるんですか？ うん
チャンダーが一人になってくると
あの 中性でしょ タマラも中性だからコンパウンドは中性なんです
と思いますけどね  ただ中性でニーという形
あります  ありますか  うん
格は何になるんですか？ ん？ 格は何になるんでしょうか
これは格は単数にしていますけど
ヤーヤンだからね アヤンだからね
ヤーアヤンはよーアヤンの
だからアヤンでしょ アヤンっていうのは単数
え 女性と男性です  どちらでも入りますからね
はい  女性だったらアヤン
まあアヤンとそちらの破格変化は今思い出せませんですけどね
アヤンイメイマニっていう風になりますけどね
中性のデクレンションはね
イマアヤンイマ イマヨなんですね
女性名詞は アヤンイメっていうのは男性のディテンションですよ
[咳]だからアヤンっていう場合は中性と男性の単数なんですよ
で そこでタガラチャンダナニって言ってたところはもう複数形にした方が正しいんだけどね
で もうでもあれが単数だから分かりません
私はそういうところは一応表面的にはこれはもう単数で取らなくちゃいけないんですが
意味としては複数にもなるし
例えばコンパウンドであろうとも
それはこのチェはくっつくコンパウンドでしょうしね
だからタガランチェタンジャナンと言えばタガラタンジャナンという風にコンパウンドになって
それはチャンダナ [咳]あるいはこのチャンダン
うん わからないね チャンダニ
チャンダニンというふうにリングキーと考えた場合ですね
うん  そういう匂いを持ってる人というふうに解することができんですが
ああ そうそうそう それはできますね
なるほど  そこまで考えるのはちょっとお考えすぎですか
うん それは それは可能です
そういう考え方もあるんですか
うん その方がもっとよりぴったし締まってきますと思いますけどね
一般的にタガラチャンダナと訳しますけど
その方がより締まってきます
いわゆる香水つけてるこの連中よりは
あの戒律を守っている人の香りがすごいという訳だったら
もっといいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
ありがとうございます
では それで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます